today's video is sponsored by keeps but
more on that in just a moment
[Music]
[Applause]
square kilometers or some 77 000 square
miles today's protagonist is a country
that has recently stood out for three
main reasons first for being considered
no less than the last dictatorship in
Europe second for having played and
continuing to play a key role in the
Russian invasion of Ukraine and thirdly
in exactly the same vein for being the
only European Ally left to Vladimir
Putin's Russia of course we are talking
about Alexander lukashenko's Belarus
never before had this country played
such a prominent role remember that this
was the country where the Wagner agreed
to take refuge after mutining and
marching on Moscow also it is the place
where the very invasion of Ukraine
actually began on the 24th of February
2022. don't forget that the first
Russian offensive started from the
Belarusian region of homil and that was
not all at the same time in parallel
with the advance of ground troops the
Russian Air Force launched dozens of
attacks against Ukrainian targets with
aircraft and missiles that took off and
were launched from Belarus
despite lukashenko's historic promises
that Ukraine would never be attacked
from his country the Russian plans to
take over Kiev in 72 hours had Belarus
playing an absolutely key role those who
reproach us didn't you know that we have
the closest Alliance with the Russian
Federation with them we are building a
single powerful independent state the
union state we have been and will be
together with fraternal Russia our
participation in the Special Operation
was decided by me a long time ago since
then this has been by far the country
most affected by International sanctions
both economically and politically some
of this country's best known companies
have even decided to leave the country
take wargaming for example the developer
of well-known games such as this one
belarus's biggest games company is
leaving the country and Russia World of
Tanks developer wargaming to close
Studios and transfer operation of games
but do you know what none of of this is
even the worst of it the worst thing is
that a long time after the war started
it is no longer Ukraine's sovereignty
that is at risk but that of Belarus
itself yeah you heard me right this
country could disappear in the not too
distant future and not precisely by
being invaded by Ukraine or NATO Belarus
runs the risk of being annexed by the
great Russian bear without going any
further the Ukrainian Parliament itself
considers that Russia has de facto
already occupied it this is practically
the same position held by the Belarusian
opposition in Exile and this has caused
all of us here at visualpolitik to ask a
few key questions to what extent is
Belarus at risk of being annexed by
Russia what is behind moscow's alleged
intentions why does lukashenko seem to
be doing nothing about it well in this
video we're going to answer these and a
bunch of other questions but before we
get started Believe It or Not hair loss
is a problem that affects over 60
percent of men while there isn't a magic
cure for baldness it's possible to
prevent hair loss from worsen keeps
offers an online subscription service
allowing you to customize an FDA
approved solution based on your specific
stage of hair loss once your treatment
plan is in place your products are
discreetly shipped in non-branded
packaging choose shipment intervals of
every 3 6 or 12 months based on what
suits you best unfortunately it is a bit
late for me keeps can only stop hair
loss it cannot regenerate here so it's
best to take action in the early stages
of hair loss most keeps users observe
notable results within six months of
starting their treatment but don't just
take our word for it head to their
website and check out the reviews for
before and after photos of real men
who've had success with this program so
if this is a problem that is bothering
you or someone that you care about and
you have a Us address remember hair loss
stops with keeps for special offer to
get started go to keeps.com forward
slash visualpolitik or click the link in
the description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash visualpolitik and
now let's get cracking
thank you
[Music]
basically visual politic viewers Belarus
has one major problem From moscow's
perspective this is not really a foreign
country nor a fully independent one
instead they see it as a kind of
autonomous territory that somehow really
actually belongs to Mother Russia itself
and of course as you can imagine knowing
all the background this is extremely
disturbing but the worst thing is that
this is not an exclusively Russian
perspective
when lukashenko came to power in 1994 he
did so by winning an election in which
his campaign was based above all on
integration with Russia particularly in
the economic sphere but not only there
let's say that at the time lukashenko
received political and economic support
from Moss School in exchange for
reinforcing the Russian worldview
in fact the Belarusian identity which
for years has been promoted and
continues to be promoted by the regime
is based above all on the cult of the
Soviet past on the Great Patriotic War
as the second world war to all the rest
of us and Brotherhood with Russia about
the rest of belarus's past not a whisper
lukashenko himself has even said on
state television that belarusians in
essence are Russians with a quality seal
yup I kid you not in fact it was to a
large extent this position that explains
why in 1999 Moscow and Minsk signed a
bilateral treaty to progressively
constitute the so-called Union State in
other words the two countries decided to
merge well not merge exactly but to
strengthen to the extreme their social
political and economic integration with
joint institutions we are talking for
example about a common currency and a
unified tax code
for now it's not gone that far but from
the very beginning freedom of movement
between the two countries and the
unification of the two labor markets
were established and so Russians and
belarussians do not need permits or any
other particular documents to work in
either country but all in all the
question we have to ask is why did
Belarus decide to take this important
step so let's see apparently it had
everything to lose I mean right a small
country associating with a much larger
one it's kind of clear that Moscow would
end up making all the decisions isn't it
well actually no or at least that's not
what lukashenko thought check this out
the 1990s were very hard for Russia the
country was in a constant crisis and
this awakened the ambition of the
Belarusian leader as we have already
told you on several occasions before
here on visualpolitik lukashenko came to
think that in many joint bodies the
weight of power of Russia and Belarus
would be exactly the same he even went
so far as to think that he himself could
lead this kind of supra State obviously
the passage of time made things look
completely different to the point that
these days we are not talking about a
partnership for Belarus but about the
real risk of annexation by Russia
and the question is was lukashenko so
naive how could Europe's last dictator
be a guy who is so easily played well
the truth is that this is not actually
quite the case the Belarusian dictator
always had one eye on Russia and one eye
on the west until one day all of that
changed so what happened to make Minsk
practically surrender to Moscow well
let's find out
the calculated ambiguity
shortly after the signing of the State
of the Union treaty the commodity and
oil super cycle began which Consolidated
Putin's first period at the helm of
Russia during those years dollars
started flowing into Russia like there
was no tomorrow and of course Belarus
benefited from that sudden wave of
prosperity its exports to the Russian
giant skyrocketed many young people
moved to the neighboring country to work
and naturally direct investment by
Russian companies in the country
multiplied these were the golden years
of lukashenko's Belarus but as the
saying goes All That Glitters Is Not
Gold there is a problem a big problem
that kept the Belarusian dictator awake
at night soon after Putin came to power
lukashenko understood perfectly well
that the new Russian leader was not like
Yeltsin and that therefore his plans to
Pilot The Joint State they had agreed to
create were doomed to Absolute failure
as a result they started dragging their
feet on the project in Minsk and not
only that when oil prices deflated the
Belarusian government took the
opportunity to stop looking directly to
Moscow and to start paying more
attention to the West the target was the
giant European Union Market
[Music]
and that's not even all it also began to
cultivate a national identity of its own
one that went beyond Russia for example
in 2014 several Russian media Outlets
began to blame the Belarusian leader for
flirting with nationalism and trying to
supplant Russian culture there is an
Undeclared Russia phobic campaign in
Belarus and nationalist forces are being
openly pandered to the government slyly
took all sorts of measures some are
symbolic as replacing Saint George
ribbons which were widely used as
celebrations with green red ribbons
imitating the colors of the official
flag also in 2018 the regime went so far
as to allow some say even encourage
public celebrations for the 100th
anniversary of the Belarusian Republic
that was declared in 1918 after
temporarily succeeding from Russia this
had been the first attempt at National
Independence in its modern history and
as you can imagine it's a symbol for
nationalist movements but these are just
two examples of a movement that clearly
sought to reinforce a true national
identity for the first time
not surprisingly by that time the
Belarusian regime had already become
much more cautious about Putin's new
Russia they did not trust it they knew
that if they did not consolidate a clear
national identity and start looking for
commercial and economic Alternatives the
country would sooner or later be
swallowed up by Russia they were even
willing to give up certain subsidies in
exchange for more economic and political
Independence at that time Beyond
appearances the truth is that relations
between Minsk and Moscow were not
exactly the best in fact in early 2020
Russia went so far as to cut off oil
supplies to this country and
re-established Border controls on the
movement of people to give you an idea
of how things stood lukashenko refused
at all times to recognize the Russian
annexation of Crimea for him Crimea was
still Ukraine and he also made
statements like this one Belarus would
never allow other countries to use our
territory for military intervention in
Ukraine the problem is looking to the
West is sometimes easier said than done
especially if you are a dictatorship
with an Iron Fist and a terribly
obsolete economy in the case of Belarus
all that it could export to the European
Union were basically Commodities and low
value added products wood metal potatoes
and above all petrochemical products
you see Belarus has a huge installed
capacity to produce fuels and oil
derivatives so what's the problem that
the whole industry the largest in the
country basically depends on the supply
of cheap Russian oil and so while it
increased its exports to the West it
increased its dependence on Russia it
was not an easy situation but in any
case the truth was that the distance
between Moscow and Minsk was increasing
and doing so quickly you could say it
was the great opportunity to take
Belarus out of the Kremlin sphere of
control once and for all nevertheless
visual politic viewers in 2020 this
whole process suddenly fell apart and no
it was not because of what you were
thinking the crucial event in this whole
story was not covid-19 but the
presidential elections check this out
on the 9th of August 2020 presidential
elections were held lukashenko's
candidacy officially won just over 80
percent of the vote of course these
elections were almost as rigged as a
track and field race involving Kim
Jong-un in North Korea and the result
sparked huge peaceful protests demanding
a game change in the country the
protests were so large and had so much
international support that for the first
time the Belarusian regime was kind of
on the ropes and that's not even all to
make matters worse the belarusians began
to withdraw money on Mass from the banks
and tried by all means to convert their
local rubles into stronger currencies
such as the dollar or the euro in case
anything should happen within a month
the belarusians practically exhausted
all the reserves of the Central Bank and
institutions such as the IMF refused to
come to their aid the country was on the
verge of collapse and lukashenko's
dictatorship seemed to be hanging by a
thread it was only one way out to throw
himself into Russia's arms
and guess what no sooner said than done
that's exactly what he did
the Belarusian regime asked Vladimir
Putin for help and within days Russia
approved a first bailout of 1.5 billion
dollars then along with that Financial
bailout Russia also promised you guessed
it military assistance Vladimir Putin
has offered to send military assistance
to support Belarus President Alexander
lukashenko has up to 200 000 protesters
gathered to demand his removal on top of
that the Kremlin also sent all kinds of
propaganda and repression professionals
without going any further the television
channels were practically taken over by
Russian propagandists propagandists too
were naturally under orders from Moscow
and not Minsk be lies at me the point is
that with all this help and with the
guarantee that the Russian army would
prevent any kind of Uprising against the
Belarusian government lukashenko was
able to increase the repression and
persecution of all political opposition
without fearing the consequences in 2021
this even happened remember Ryanair
confirms that Belarus has forced one of
its planes to land and exactly the
Belarusian Air Force forced the Ryanair
plane flying between Athens and Vilnius
to land in Minsk in order to arrest
Roman krutasovich and his partner Sophia
sapega protasovich is a journalist and
critical opposition activist with asylum
in the European Union to force a
European commercial airliner to land
between two European cities even sending
a fighter jet to make it happen and all
of that to detain a person who has
political asylum in Europe obviously
that meant Crossing all of the red lines
but at that time in Minsk thanks to
moscow's support they could afford to do
it there was only one problem gifts are
almost never free and they certainly
weren't in this case
in return for all this help the
Belarusian dictator had to Grant the
Kremlin far more influence than ever
before he even had to commit himself to
pushing through a constitutional reform
that would for example allow the
permanent deployment of Russian troops
in the country crazy as you can imagine
this whole process was accompanied by a
lot of new sanctions from the
International Community which obviously
further deepened the country's
dependence on Russia let's just say that
the era of looking to the West had come
to an end for good and that it was at
this point that everything changed for
years Belarus had strongly opposed the
opening of Russian military bases in the
country they understood logically that
this posed an intolerable threat after
the rescue of 2020 however there was no
choice but to give in to Russian demands
for example in addition to Growing
military ties from 2020 onwards strong
anti-western rhetoric was also launched
by the Belarusian government the State
of the Union returned to the front page
in 2021 tens of thousands of migrants
from the Middle East and Africa were
used to cause a political and
humanitarian crisis on the border with
Poland and Lithuania and in November of
that same year Minsk recognized Crimea
as part of Russia for the first time
what's more an intensive russification
program was also launched in the country
even sculptures of the rulers of the
grand duchy of Lithuania were removed
from the National Museum from that point
on the past of Belarus could only at
least officially pass through Russia
however it is not only political factors
the ties with the rest of the world and
cultural identity issues that endanger
the independence of Belarus the truth is
that this country is more and more
intertwined with Russia in fact it's
still difficult very difficult to say
that it's still an independent country
you want to know exactly what we're
talking about well then
check this out
a hostile takeover bit
visual politic Community the Russian
invasion of Ukraine made Belarus a
pariah State and completely marginalized
it on International markets the
International Community applied
practically the same sanctions as it did
to Russia with one big difference this
country has no oil gas or nuclear
technology to play with on the global
geopolitical chessboard in fact Belarus
has nothing to play with and that
explains why sanctions here have been
much more devastating than in Russia
itself for example in the first months
of the war alone Belarusian exports to
the European Union plummeted by almost
60 percent some of the most thriving
companies left the country industry had
to lay off more than 15 percent of its
workers wages in the sanction sector's
limited and the economy as a whole fell
by an optimistic five percent in 2020
and of course as we have already told
you all of this has made Belarus today
much more dependent on motherland Russia
than ever before but now the question we
have to ask is how far does all this
dependence really go
well the truth is that it's almost total
it is so extensive that one of the
country's major sources of public
Revenue consists of reselling on the
international market part of the oil it
receives at subsidized prices from
Russia according to estimates we are
talking about a profit in 2022 of 1.7
billion dollars from this operation
alone in 2023 and is expected to be
almost 3 billion dollars obviously in
Russia they know about this operation
and guess what ultimately they don't
care they are the ones in control of the
crude oil tap in fact one of the
country's main exports is fuels produced
from Russian oil something that for
years was encouraged by Moscow what
better way to control a country if its
main industry depends exclusively on you
and it's not even just the oil it
resales of the fuel it exports in total
more than two-thirds of the energy the
country consumes either comes from
Russia or is controlled by Russian
companies in other words in the current
context if Moscow were to turn off the
tap Belarus would practically go dark
but let's look Beyond energy about half
of all the countries public debt is in
Russian hands then with foreign direct
investment it is a very similar story
and to top it off many Russian
state-owned companies control key Assets
in Belarus we're talking about Banks
telecommunications companies and
refineries even worse it is estimated
that today 60 to 70 percent of all
Belarusian exports go to the land of
Vladimir Putin in other words from an
economic point of view we can no longer
speak of a completely independent
country
[Music]
yeah
and all of this explains why when Russia
wanted to invade Ukraine and take Kiev
in three days it used this country
lukashenko could not oppose it in fact
since the beginning of the invasion in
Ukraine the country has been one of the
main bases for missile launches has
given the Russian Armed Forces a
substantial part of its military
arsenals has allowed them intensive use
of its railroads and Roads and has even
become a key Medical Center for soldiers
fallen or wounded at the front
[Music]
but wait a minute this is nothing new so
why do we say that there is now a real
risk of annexation by Russia well
because Belarus may end up becoming a
kind of consolation price think about it
however the Ukrainian war ends it is
clear that the campaign has been and
will be a resounding failure and
obviously no Tyrant likes to present
himself as defeated Putin promised to
protect Russia and make it bigger and
that is no longer happening in Ukraine
for years Belarus tried to juggle to
take advantage of the Russian bear
without falling completely into its
clutches now that is no longer possible
Putin knows this and seems more than
willing to take advantage of this
situation one way would we divorce an
annexation to Russia under the framework
of the union state or some other
political intervention such as the
recreation of the satellite states of
the former Soviet Union in this way he
could sell the picture of a bigger and
stronger rusher a success in the
framework of tremendous political
economic and Military defeat from the
kremlin's point of view not a bad move
don't you think
thank you Metropolitan Community all
indications are that Belarus is in one
way or another maybe on the verge of
losing its sovereignty if it is not
already lost it the attempt to Harbor
the Wagner's was perhaps lukasenko's
last attempt to secure more room to
maneuver but with the fall of pregosian
That's History now as it stands Belarus
is likely to disappear from the map be
that as it may and given that we do not
have a crystal ball the best thing we
can do is to open a respectful debate do
you think that Russia will definitely
Annex Belarus will turn it into a
completely subordinate state or on the
contrary will lukashenko and the rest of
Minx managers be able to keep their
heads what should the West do about this
whole Saga leave us your answers in the
comments below and of course if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to like And subscribe to all of
us here at visualpolitik if you haven't
already done so thanks very much for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video
and I'll see you next time
[Music]